rückholaktion wegen corona krise die
bundesregierung spricht eine weltweite
reisewarnung aus und will tausende
gestrandete urlauber heimholen
notfallplan für deutsche krankenhäuser
in reha kliniken hotels und messehallen
sollen weitere krankenbetten
bereitgestellt werden
keine fußball party in diesem sommer die
uefa verschiebt die europameisterschaft
auf juni 2021
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und herzlich
willkommen bei den heute -nachrichten am
dienstag dem 17
märz und sie handeln wen wundert's
hauptsächlich von der korona krise die
dafür sorgt dass wir auf unsere gewohnte
mobilität weitgehend verzichten müssen
auch das hat es so noch nie gegeben das
auswärtige amt spricht eine reisewarnung
aus und diesmal gilt sie für die ganze
welt
der appell von außenminister maß heute
bitte bleiben sie zu hause für die
deutschen aber die in entlegeneren
urlaubsgebieten gestrandet sind startet
die bundesregierung eine beispiellose
rückholaktion wegen der massiven
einschränkungen im flugverkehr sitzen
nämlich tausende touristen weltweit fest
zuerst werden deutsche aus ländern wie
marokko der dominikanischen republik
ägypten den malediven und den
philippinen ausgeflogen linken klinge
mit dieser sondermaschine aus barbados
landen am vormittag kreuzfahrt reisende
aus der karibik der reiseveranstalter
hat sie vorzeitig zurück geholt daher
sind die heimkehrer eher enttäuscht als
erleichtert wir wären lieber länger da
geblieben wir waren jetzt vier tage auf
barbados zwei wochen wollten wir da
bleiben und die kreuzfahrt machen sehr
gut man weiß nicht ob die hier
irgendwann alles zu machen und man nicht
mehr zurück fliegen kann
viele im ausland gestrandete urlauber
sind beunruhigt zum beispiel im
menschenleeren marrakesch und wir
konnten aber auf einen flug der
irgendwann ende märz geht und
das realistisch sehen möchte wäre
hoffnungslos am flughafen leute bedeutet
danach die bundesregierung will jetzt
festsitzende urlauber gezielt
zurückholen und stellt dafür 50
millionen euro bereit
dafür hat das auswärtige amt gestern mit
kommerziellen flug anflug anbietern
vereinbart ein einmaliges programm
aufzulegen mit dem wir zunächst im laufe
der nächsten tage deutsche
pauschalreisende aus besonders
betroffenen gebieten zurückholen
damit nicht noch mehr deutsche im
ausland stranden war das auswärtige amt
jetzt vor urlaubsreisen in alle länder
weltweit
die reisewarnung ist eben nur eine
warnung das heißt niemand ist
verpflichtet zu hause zu bleiben oder
die reise abzubrechen
allerdings sollte man das schon ernst
nehmen weil wirklich die gefahr besteht
dass man nicht mehr zurück kommt nach
deutschland
die erste lufthansa-maschine der rückhol
aktion startet noch heute abend richtung
philippinen in der korona krise versucht
jedes land sich und seine bürger
bestmöglich zu schützen
bisher ohne zu warten bis sich die
europäische union auf eine linie
geeinigt hat doch heute unternehmen die
27 eu staaten einen neuen anlauf um
gemeinsam gegen die verbreitung des
virus vorzugehen
ziel ist ein einreise stopp für
nicht-eu-bürger wie in
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
gestern schon vorgeschlagen hat frage an
anne gellinek in brüssel worauf genau
wollen sich die 27 staats und
regierungschefs heute abend verständigen
oberstes ziel dieses virtuellen
eu-gipfels ist natürlich ein signal der
geschlossenheit der europäischen
geschlossenheit in die welt zu senden
und das könnte beim thema eu
außengrenzen auch gelingen denn es
scheint als ob alle 27 staats und
regierungschefs den vorschlag der
eu-kommission einen 30-tägigen einreise
stopp für nicht europäer in die eu zu
verhängen es scheint als ob alle länder
dieses in ihren jeweiligen ländern
umsetzen und beschließen
schwieriger wird es allerdings bei der
diskussion um die binnengrenzen
denn hier haben wir einen europäischen
flickenteppich jedes land macht was es
will obwohl alle auch vor diesem gipfel
gesagt haben dass sie die vorschläge die
empfehlungen der eu-kommission für eine
gemeinsame für ein gemeinsames
grenzmanagement im prinzip gut heißen
es gibt wenig anzeichen dafür dass sich
der flickenteppich nach diesem gipfel
ändern könnte die situation in europa
entwickelt sich zu schnell zu dynamisch
und die eu kommission ist mit ihren
vorschlägen zur langsamkeit verdammt
weil sie sich immer mit allen 27 staaten
abstimmen muss zuletzt soll der gipfel
noch eine durchhalteparole an die
europäische wirtschaft senden und das
maßnahmenpaket der eu-kommission mit 38
milliarden euro hilfen 38 millionen euro
natürlich für die europäischen
gesundheitssysteme und unternehmen
absegnen
vielen dank an gellinek nach brüssel
immer wieder hat die eu auch darauf
gedrungen die grenzen für den
güterverkehr offen zu halten
doch nachdem polen seine grenzen
geschlossen hat geht dort fast nichts
mehr
auf mehr als 40 kilometer stauen sich
die fahrzeuge auf deutscher seite mehr
als 18 stunden wartezeit für lastwagen
mehr als zwölf stunden für autofahrer an
manchen übergängen technisches hilfswerk
und rettungsdienste versorgten die
menschen mit dem nötigsten
deutschland rüstet sich für eine weitere
ausbreitung bund und länder haben einen
krankenhaus notfallplan beschlossen
hotels und hallen sollen umfunktioniert
werden um dort die leichteren fälle
behandeln zu können
inzwischen sind hier 23 menschen an dem
virus gestorben
und auch die infektionszahlen steigen
rasant 8604 menschen haben sich
angesteckt mindestens 500 davon müssen
im krankenhaus behandelt werden und es
wird damit gerechnet dass es noch in
dieser woche deutlich mehr werden
susan von lojewski zur lage in den
kliniken schulung an einem
beatmungsgerät im klinikum stuttgart
wird personal aus allen bereichen noch
mal auf den neuesten stand gebracht
schon jetzt liegen hier schwer kranke
menschen auch vier coruna
über die hälfte der geplanten
operationen wurde abgesagt man will
platz schaffen einen bau hat der
klinikchef ganz räumen und isolieren
lassen 80 intensivbetten hat das
krankenhaus und arbeitet mit hochdruck
daran die zahl deutlich aufzustocken
fast jedes jahr 2200 zimmer im klinikum
stuttgart ist mit sauerstoff
ausgestaltet werden 30.000 liter
sauerstoff in den tanks wie mobile
beatmungsgeräte 50 operationssäle mit
narkose geräten die wir dafür
zweckentfremden könnten insofern
deutlich über 150 wenn es hart auf hart
werden eine intensive kraftanstrengung
sowie in stuttgart verlangt der
präsident des robert koch institutes
heute von allen deutschen kliniken
wir fordern das seit vielen wochen und
nochmal ganz klar haltig wir erwarten
dass von allen ausstellern dass sie ihre
intensiv kapazitäten mindestens
verdoppeln heftiger widerspruch von der
deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft für
sie ist die verdoppelung ein ding der
unmöglichkeit
dafür haben wir weder das personal noch
haben wir dafür die medizintechnik aber
wir erweitern unsere kapazitäten ich
gehe davon aus dass es realistisch sein
dürfte dass wir in den kommenden zwei
monaten bis zu 20 prozent mehr
kapazitäten zur verfügung haben in
stuttgart haben sie ihr personal noch
besser durchgeplant hier wollen sie den
wettlauf mit der zeit in jedem fall
gewinnen
justizministerin lambrecht warnt vor
falschen nachrichten zur corona krise im
netz sie appelliert an die verantwortung
der sozialen netzwerke und jedes
einzelnen fake news müssen sofort
gelöscht werden
auch die bundesbank ging heute an die
öffentlichkeit die nachricht die
bargeldversorgung ist gesichert
volker dotzel die bange frage am
geldautomaten haben sich sicher schon
viele gestellt ob den banken wohl
irgendwann das geld ausgeht die
bundesbank versichert heute nochmal die
tresore sind voll und die experten sagen
auch das virus bleibt nicht an scheinen
und münzen haften und nicht nur
geldscheine alle anderen oberflächen
auch koffer kleidungsstücke und was
immer gefragt wird sind nicht der
typische übertragungsweg für dieses
virus abstriche machen und testen das
ist derzeit der einzige weg bis die
letzte welle der korona infektionen
durch ist können allerdings noch monate
ins land gehen
bei diesem virus scheint es so zu sein
nach dem heutigen wissen dass etwa die
hälfte überhaupt nur krank wenn das
heißt die andere hälfte sehen wir ja gar
nicht die sind infiziert haben nichts
gemerkt haben eine immunität ja also wir
reden auf jeden fall über monate wir
gehen wir von einem zeitraum von zwei
jahren aus er ist positiv auf das virus
getestet worden friedrich merz das
bestätigt ein sprecher des kandidaten
für den cdu vorsitz mit fragen
bombardiert werden die arbeitsagenturen
mehr als zehnmal so viele anrufe wie
sonst die agentur reagiert kunden
müssten termine nicht absagen leistungen
würden deswegen nicht gekürzt
in münchen haben sich auch arbeitgeber
in die schlange eingereiht
teamgeist für deutschland den zeigen
stellvertretend für viele helfer diese
mitarbeiter der uniklinik des saarlandes
per facebook schreiben sie wir bleiben
für euch da bleibt ihr bitte für uns
daheim
der blick in manche supermärkte macht
einigen bürgern angst viele regale
werden immer noch leer gekauft die sorge
vor engpässen sei aber weiter
unbegründet betont die bundesregierung
hamsterkäufe seien nicht nur unnötig
sagt ministerin klöckner
sie schadeten auch es gebe aber nicht
die absicht besonders begehrte waage
waren zu rationieren britta spiekermann
berichtet in diesen corona zeiten sind
gute nachrichten mangelware ministern
klöckner übernahm heute den partner
optimistin
sie stellte klar der handel ist bestrebt
regale zeit mal wieder aufzufüllen es
ist genug für alle da hamsterkäufe
sollten möglichst unterlassen werden
leere regale seien nur eine
momentaufnahme künftig werden viele
supermärkte auch sonntags öffnen
ein käufer sollten aber nicht nur am
wochenende sondern über die woche
verteilt stattfinden
bisher sieht man keine notwendigkeit
kunden nur vereinzelt in die geschäfte
zu lassen
im moment gibt es immer mehr keine
hinweise auch von unserer schwester
würde im robert-koch-institut dass wir
eben auch vereinzelung bringen sondern
wir haben ja viele bereiche des
öffentlichen lebens wo menschen jedoch
in kontakt kommen wie wir heute hier
auch wo ihm bisher die notwendigkeit
nicht gesehen wurde
die menschen so stark zu vereinzeln das
überhaupt keinen kontakt miteinander
haben
die heimische landwirtschaft sei gut
aufgestellt trotz bewohner trotz
personalengpässen versuche man nach plan
zu arbeiten begonnen wichtig für die
ernährung ist beispielsweise weizen
insbesondere für brot und mehl
herstellung jede helfende hand werde
gebraucht klöckners vorschlag wenn der
gastronomie seinen job verloren habe
könne wechseln in unkonventionellen
zeiten oder in schwierigen zeiten muss
man auch kreative lösungen finden dass
die menschen die wollen und auch können
ohne große bürokratische hürden auch in
der landwirtschaft arbeiten können
landwirtschaft und lebensmittelindustrie
sprechen von einer gesicherten
versorgung die politik gesetzt auf
flexibilität auf allen ebenen wie sehr
sich die korona krise wirtschaftlich bei
uns auswirkt zeigt sich vor allem in der
deutschen autoindustrie
volkswagen stellt die produktion ab
donnerstag für die nächsten wochen
weitgehend ein
vor allem weil die lieferketten reisen
heißt es und zum schutz der belegschaft
und weil die nachfrage rapide sinkt
oliver deuker jahre ist wie lang
pressekonferenz von volkswagen live im
internet statt vor journalisten aus
aller welt das positive 2009 10 war ein
erfolgreiches jahr für den weltgrößten
autobauer
düstere aussichten aber für 2020
absatzeinbrüche aktuell von rund 25
prozent volkswagen schließt
vorübergehend 14 werke in europa die
korona pandemie stellt uns vor
ungekannte operative und finanzielle
herausforderung angesichts der sich
aktuell deutlich verschlechternden
absatzlage und der sich abzeichnenden
unsicherheit bei der teileversorgung
unserer werke wird es an den standorten
unserer marken unmittelbar auch zu
produktionsunterbrechungen
kommen die automobilindustrie weltweit
bedroht von corona virus mit schwer
absehbaren folgen in china hatten wir
den zusammenbruch des marktes in europa
haben wir den zusammenbruch des marktes
derzeit wie wir ihn erleben und amerika
könnte folgen also alle drei großen
kernmärkte
das hat er die welt bisher noch nicht
erlebt die schlimmste krise
nach unserer einschätzung seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
mehr als 800.000 mitarbeiter
deutschlandweit in der kfz-industrie
wenn die autobauer hierzulande husten
heißt es hat deutschland eine grippe wir
müssen uns jetzt darauf konzentrieren so
schnell wie möglich wieder in ein
normales wirtschaftsleben zurückkehren
zu können
aber das jetzt eben auch eine
wirkungsvolle bekämpfung des virus
voraus selbst wenn die korona krise nur
drei monate anhalten sollte so
autoexperte dudenhöffer würde es bis zu
zehn jahre dauern bis sich die situation
normalisiere
und auch bei mercedes sollen ab dieser
woche viele bänder stillstehen peter
kunz in hannover ist die autoindustrie
das herz unserer wirtschaft dabei nur
der anfang
so sieht's aus viele bereiche gerade
auch im maschinenbau und der
elektroindustrie sind betroffen
teile können nicht mehr zugeliefert
werden weil sie zum beispiel nicht mehr
auf der straße durch frankreich oder
italien nach deutschland transportiert
werden können aber stehen auch plötzlich
die exporte da die maschinen für den
export teuer vorfinanziert können sie
weltweit nicht mehr ausgeliefert werden
bezahlt werden sie aber auch erst wenn
sie dann auf der anderen seite stehen um
laufen im maschinenbau trifft das eine
branche die sowieso schon im letzten
jahr in die rezession gerutscht ist das
top deutschland insgesamt ja noch
bevorstehen könnte
ein bisschen sehen wir jetzt sozusagen
den reflex der globalisierung sie hat
uns alle reicher gemacht aber auch
anfälliger und sowas daherkommt wie ein
globales virus danke für die einordnung
peter kunst in hannover im kampf gegen
das virus hat auch frankreich nun
drastische maßnahmen ergriffen
besonders einschneidend eine
ausgangssperre für alle das heißt seit
heute mittag dürfen die menschen nur
noch das haus verlassen wenn sie
zwingende gründe nachweisen können das
neue leben mit der ausgangssperre in
paris
es teilt auch unsere korrespondentin
christel hass gründlich um 12 uhr sind
sie da polizisten kontrollieren ob die
die auf der straße sind auch ihren
berechtigungsschein parat haben
er hatte ihn nicht und ist mit einer
verwarnung davon gekommen sie haben mich
ermahnt und gesagt dass ich immer dabei
haben muss zusammen mit dem ausweis zu
hause bleiben ist die order für die
nächsten zwei wochen in frankreich
heraus darf nur wer zur arbeit geht zum
arzt oder einkaufen
auch sport ist erlaubt aber nur allein
und eben mit bescheinigung
das ist notwendig es ist eine epidemie
die sich unglaublich schnell verbreitet
jeder kann sich anstecken
[Musik]
viele wollen jetzt raus aus der engen
hauptstadt aufs land doch es fahren nur
wenige züge
ob das was wir haben draußen mehr platz
seinen garten und können diese
schwierige zeit mit der familie
verbringen aber nie fern von den
bahnhöfen wird paris seltsam still
nach den drastischen worten des
präsidenten gestern abend wir sind in
einem gesundheits krieg wir kämpfen
wieder gegen eine armee noch wegen einer
anderen nation
aber der feind ist da unsichtbar und er
breitet sich aus schon vor der
ankündigung des präsidenten hatte ein
sturm auf die supermärkte eingesetzt
obwohl die lebensmittelläden offen
bleiben
am anfang habe ich mir kaum sorgen
gemacht aber jetzt habe ich wirklich
angst
frankreich kämpft gegen korona und hofft
dass die sonst so aufmüpfigen bürger den
ernst der lage erkannt haben
der zdf-fernsehrat ganz im zeichen der
kroner krise unter anderem in einem zdf
spezial direkt nach uns und auch in
einem maybrit illner spezial
natürlich bleiben sie immer auf dem
laufenden online in einem live blog auf
heute de und in der heute app jetzt ist
es beschlossen die fußball-em wird wegen
der korona pandemie verschoben auf
sommer 2021 der neue termin ist also ein
jahr später es ist der versuch
planungssicherheit für den profifußball
zu schaffen
vielleicht gelingt es ja so noch die
unterbrochene bundesliga saison zu ende
zu bringen
marc windgassen hat die details auf
diese bilder wird man dieses jahr
verzichten müssen keine fanmeilen kein
kollektiver fußballrausch und nicht nur
die deutsche fangemeinde braucht geduld
erst im nächsten jahr findet sie jetzt
statt die fußball-em und der alte termin
gecancelt gespielt wird vom 11
juni bis zum 11 juli 2021 den
verantwortlichen um ihren chef alexander
ferien blieb ihnen dann heute doch keine
andere wahl
europa aktuell zentrum der korona krise
als austragungsort und denkbar
auch der dfb hat inzwischen reagiert
sein präsident fritz keller über den
eigenen social media kanal ein statement
abgegeben
nur wenn wir solidarisch handeln dann
können wir diese krise zusammen
überstehen es gibt keine alternative zur
verschiebung der europameisterschaft in
rom wäre das eröffnungsspiel dieser em
gewesen auch in münchen wäre gespielt
wurden sowie in zehn weiteren städten
das ist jetzt vorübergehend geschichte
mit der verlegung hat die uefa und damit
auch der profifußball insgesamt erst
einmal etwas an zeit gewonnen doch damit
einher geht auch dass sowohl frauen als
auch u21 em auf unbestimmte zeit verlegt
werden und ein terminchaos 2021 droht
viel arbeit wartet also jetzt auf die
uefa termine müssen gefunden
finanzierungen erstellt werden den
nationalen ligen jedenfalls bringt es
die gewünschte pause so auch der
bundesliga ob mit oder ohne zuschauer
irgendwie soll die saison noch zu ende
gebracht werden
in schwierigen situationen wie sie
derzeit herrschen entstehen auch neue
ideen zum beispiel in chicago das
aquarium dort ist für besucher wegen der
korona krise geschlossen
deshalb dürfen die die sonst bestaunt
werden die neue freiheit für einen
kleinen rundgang nutzen die pinguine
besuchen einfach mal ihre nachbarn und
sind genauso neugierig wie die besucher
sonst klar warum auch nicht zum wetter
an den küsten regnet es etwas aber sonst
wird es ein schöner sonniger tag zu den
einzelheiten gleich gunther tiersch hier
geht es jetzt gleich weiter mit einem
zdf spezial zu den wirtschaftlichen
folgen der korona krise ich danke ihnen
für ihr interesse und wünsche ihnen
einen entspannten abend bis morgen
[Musik]
einige zuschauer sie können sich auf
einen sonnigen warmen tag morgen freuen
nur an der küste da muss man eben noch
wind wolken und ein bisschen regen
trotzen
aber es ist ja noch warm in mitteleuropa
15 bis 20 grad erwarten wir am wärmsten
ist es ganz im südwesten iberische
halbinsel bis zu 25 grad portugal und
spanien aber in diesen zeiten nutzen uns
das derzeit auch nicht viel
und heute nacht wird sogar frostig
werden also in den mittelgebirgen geht
es runter bis auf minus 1 grad sonst
bleibt es frostfrei im süden verletzter
regen langsam deutschland da bieten sich
dann bis morgen früh nebelfeldern
flussniederungen am main am rhein oder
auch an der donau und tagsüber haben wir
einen neuen regen der cd an der küste
auch von der nordsee über
schleswig-holstein nachmittags erreicht
er vielleicht auch die ostseeküste ist
lebend frischer südwestwind dazu ja auf
dem weg nach süden lockert es dann aber
mehr und mehr auf und in der mitte und
in süddeutschland scheint die sonne
herrlicher tag teilweise ein wolkenloser
himmel dabei und die temperaturen
spielen eben auch mit am oberrhein
wahrscheinlich sogar bis zu 21 grad
sonst 14 bis 18 und nur an der nordsee
bleibt es noch ein bisschen frischer ja
ab donnerstag wird es von norden her
dann langsam etwas kühler und eben auch
wechselhafter und am samstag da haben
wir dann eben nur noch temperaturen
zwischen vier und 13 grad
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut